à l'heure d'Internet et de l'information
on continue la toile peut vite
représenter un danger pour des enfants
de 9 ou 10 ans les médias étaient donc
le thème de la Journée des droits de
l'enfant vendredi dernier à guillancourt
et les jeunes guillancourtois ont pour
l'instant un accès limité aux
technologie je m'informe un peu avec mes
parents mais
j'ai faut vraiment qu'il soit là parce
que sinon je peux regarder n'importe
quoi et donc ça peut être dangereux
quelque fois je jou sur l'ordinateur
pour jouer à des jeux mais c'est j joue
que en maximum pendant cette journée
anniversaire de la signature de la
convention internationale des droits de
l'enfant en 1989 l'objectif est
d'essayer de faire comprendre aux jeunes
élèves la multitude d'informations qui
circulent sur Internet et surtout leur
crédibilité par exemple savoir qu'une
photo peut être retouché avant sa
publication ils se sont glissés dans la
peau de journalistes en créant notamment
leur propre une de journal et en
manipulant du matériel audiovisuel des
ateliers qui vont se prolonger en classe
je vais l'intégrer complètement dans mon
programme euh travailler sur les
journaux puisquon on travaille sur un
journal d'école à l'école on est en
plein de dents euh voilà et puis bien
sûr en éducation à la citoyenité on va
reparler de tout ça la semaine prochaine
près de 500 élèves guonctois ont
participé à cette journée organisée
chaque année